hello everyone I recently watched the  trailer for the movie two guns starring  Denzel Washington and Mark Wahlberg and  in the trailer there was this amazing  shot of some donuts saying never rob a  bank across from a diner who has the  best donor seats recount so I thought  let's recreate that in slow-mo then I  carried on watching the trailer and I  saw a different shot of a red  convertible filled with money getting  blown up make it ring so we're gonna do  that instead  well I think we got some pretty gnarly  angles of that explosion money flaming  through the air I'm happy with it be  sure to follow us on Twitter and tune in  for the next video  there's a lot missing from this car even  the paint is missing